well this system can't be right we need
to find another system
what i saw as the fallout from his
action
was him getting some death threats
there's a problem with our current
system
in the fact that it does not produce you
need to take
tangible steps forward in solving this
political divide because
a country divided just doesn't work we
have to get every state involved or is
it
just a few states will start to begin to
see a difference
i think it really is going to be a slow
roll for a little bit
give them that choice with the most
representative electoral system
and whether you talk to a republican or
a democrat the one thing that everyone
can agree on is that they're not very
happy with what's going on
[Music]
welcome back to generally speaking i'm
your host general spalding today we have
shay siegert he was the campaign manager
for proposition 2 in alaska and we're
going to talk about that and he's also
the head of a couple of organizations
alaskans for better elections i think i
got that right
but welcome uh everybody shay siegert uh
[Music]
it's gonna be a great conversation so
shay uh thanks for being here
um i got your name uh from katherine
gale who i spent
a good time with and that show should
air here for
very fairly soon as well but uh she
recommended that i talk to you
and um she said that you were inspired
by
not the book that she wrote but the
report so can you
can you just talk a little bit about
what um what prompted you
to um you know really i think you
started a war with the political parties
there and
they're in alaska but um what what got
you what got you interested in
in taking this on yeah i um
so i came on um after after i had been
drafted so it was a
scott kendall was the the original
author of the bill
and and he and i and a host of
of other lawyers in in the state of
alaska
um came together around this idea that
we have
this insane political polarization
and and and really you see
the division continue to happen and you
see that
first it started with the closed
primaries
really what what um this group formed
around was
taking away the ability of five or six
percent of
any given district um taking away
that five or six percent's ability to
decide for the rest of for the other 95
of the district and what i mean by that
is you know in 2020
one thing that actually worked in our
favor for the campaign but not for the
state
was we saw nine broadly supported
bipartisanly supported um legislators
get ousted by the low end being
six percent of their district the high
end being 13
of their district and 13 said no we
don't want this person anymore
we're going to put forth this other
person who will
fall in party lines
and and what happened was was we saw a
flood of dark money come in
a flood of partisan politics come in and
play
in a very siloed off group of the most
radical voters in this closed primary
system
and so we saw this happen time after
time after time
where a politician would quite honestly
do the right thing
and they would listen to their
constituents all of their constituents
regardless of partisanship
and then they would get punished and
penalized by
our current by our former system now in
alaska
which feels really good to say um and
and they get penalized for you know
going against the
our our current governor or going
against their party and doing what's
best for
the people in their district the most
the majority of people in their district
and so we looked at that and said well
this system
can't be right we need to find another
system
and first we looked at a whole host of
of issues top two primary top two
non-partisan open primaries
uh ranked choice voting in both the
primary and
the general election finally landing on
a top four open primary
with ranked choice voting in the general
and then also
making sure that voters had the power of
information
on the financial disclosure side so we
um made it to we increased disclosure
laws
on candidate independent expenditure
groups
and and what we saw was you know people
really were sick of the partisanship
i saw it firsthand working in the
legislature in 2019
and i spent three sessions down in the
legislature but in 2019 i worked for
a gentleman by the name of
representative gary cannot and he was
from the kenai a republican
and coming out of the 2018 general
election
20 um 21 republicans
basically claimed that they had the
majority the majority caucus and they
were going to elect their speaker
well what happened was was my boss
representative gary knop
stepped out of that caucus and said a a
caucus with 21 people
in a 40-person legislature can't
can't work because then any given day
one person
can hold all of the power of the
legislative body
and so that just absolutely can't work
and so he stepped out and said i'm not
going to join a caucus
that doesn't have representation from
all sides and and what
what ended up happening was that action
formed
the only bipartisan coalition in the
entire nation
that year and what i saw as the fallout
from his action
was him getting some death threats
him getting a primary him
having a town hall where special
interest groups
shipped in people to protest
shipped in people to
cause a little bit of a ruckus during
the
during the town hall where he was simply
just trying to listen to his
constituents
and we were heading into the primary
in 2020 and
i told him i said i i got approached by
this campaign and i've
i've helped along the way with um
studying some of the things they're
trying to solve i think this really
could be a good thing and he said go do
what's best for the state
and and join this team and go win that
campaign because if you leave me and
lose that's a problem
but if you leave me and win then we're
doing well
and so i lived up to the word and won
we we created a great team but i would
say working
in the legislature and seeing it
firsthand and seeing how good
legislators
continue to get punished by this closed
primary system
and and then we elect people with a
plurality
after that it was just a system that
continued to drive us apart and apart
and apart
and not be able to focus on on the
issues at hand
that is um that sounds like a tough
battle
uh and when i heard that you know alaska
had actually voted this way in 2020 i
was
i was kind of shocked so and you guys uh
if i remember right you didn't have a
lot of money
um for your campaign um so tell me about
that that you know what how did you
actually pull this off because it seems
like you know a long shot
with the money that you had and and kind
of facing i was reading an article
before
you know this interview um where you
know both political parties went after
you
uh and said that you know you're trying
to
um take away take away alaskans right to
vote you know when exactly
when you're actually trying to give a
lasting said you know a really
worthwhile vote so tell me about that
i think you know really one thing that i
i credit
our success to um is really the fact
that
that in alaska if something's broken
people fix it also if you you
are passing someone along the road and
and they're pulled over
you don't just keep on going you stop
over and fix it you don't ask them
what political party they're a part of
because it's most likely that they're
not part of a political party because
you know people move up here or stay up
here
because they want to to experience new
adventures
they want to take care of their land
they want to
um live out on their own and be
independent which is why
you know we might that might be one of
the main reasons why we have the highest
uh percentage of of nonpartisan and
undeclared registrants
in the in this uh nation
and so in alaska we have over 60 percent
of registered voters choose not to
register as uh
either of the two major parties being
republican or democrat
we have a really independent um pull
yourself up by your bootstraps fix your
own system
don't worry about uh the lower what the
lower 48's doing
you know uh type of
way of life and so really what i think
came
it came down to was alaskans um
as a as alaskans we saw the
um dismal results that our current
system was providing we saw the divide
at our
own family dinner tables if you had uh
family members who thought one way and
other family members who thought another
you know some people would leave the
family or leave the dinner
um that's not how politics should be
politics should be an
open conversation of civil discourse and
and that's what we wanted
and that's what um alaska voters said
on november 3rd um and it was
it was quite great to see it it's it's
not a surprise having lived here for
um enough time to see the strong
independent nature of alaskans uh
it it really was a
a testament to who we are and and what
we believe in
and what we think is should be happening
in our
state capital the fed the national
capital and
you know in our own conversations so if
you're going to advise
somebody that um was in another state
you know what would be you know where
would so catherine said
there's 10 other states that are
considering similar legislation so
one of the things you did differently
from the book is you had a final four
instead of a final five
how did you arrive at final four and
then how would you uh recommend
people get involved at a local level in
their state to begin
to make this change yeah and
and i'll attack the first question first
and answer that
i would say start having these
conversations with anyone and everyone
it's something that that you know all
voters can agree
is something that all voters can agree
to is that there's a problem with our
current system
when we're tackling covid issues when
we're
tackling um revenue uh sources
and and balanced budgets there's a
problem with our current system
in the fact that it does not produce
there's also a problem with our current
system and the fact that
we have a public approval rating of our
legislature
our national uh congress of
eight nine ten percent today maybe it's
seven percent today but yet our
retention rate is up in the high
90s of incumbent legislators that is
not a system that's serving the voter
when 92 percent or
yeah 92 percent of the um
electorate says you're not doing your
job correctly yet we continue to hire
that person
you there might be an issue there and so
really having that conversation but
extending that conversation
all of us like to talk about the
problems in washington dc or
our own state capitals but when it comes
time for a solution
it kind of falls down to viability
says well yeah that would be great but
do you think that could ever happen
do you think we could actually ever you
know take on the
the two-party system or take on this
electoral system and change it for the
better and normally the conversation
ends at
no not really we can't do that and
that's that's the problem
is that we have the solution right in
front of us it's final five or final
four voting
um and and really whether you do final
four or final five it's it's kind of
arbitrary to
the fact that you need to take tangible
steps forward
in solving this political divide because
a country divided
just doesn't work it's not a country at
all um
and so we we continue to need to take
these tangible steps
and so as for final four versus
final five we started at final four and
and um back when
this all was getting drafted basically
we decided that final four would be the
adequate
four would be the adequate number
because we have um
a republican a democrat and then we can
get other parties
represented as well because we have
strong third parties we have a strong
libertarian
party here in alaska we have a strong um
green party here in alaska but really
what it's what it's about is giving
everyone the equal and equal opportunity
to get to the general ballot
regardless of partisanship treating
candidates
and voters the same one thing i said
during the campaign a lot was
no matter who you talk to you really
expect
uh legislators to work across party
lines
you expect them to work together and
compromise and work towards the greater
good
but when we go to vote in the a closed
primary system
we don't let ourselves vote across party
lines how we expect our legislators to
act
in juneau or in our our state capitol
across the nation
and so that's the problem is that you
know we expect these
these legislators to to work and vote
across party lines but yet we don't let
our voters vote across party lines
and and so attacking those systemic
issues
can lead to better results
people taking stands for the betterment
of their constituents
making the only special interest that
matters in this whole political process
be one group of people which is the the
voters
so i think that's really uh what gets to
the essence of that question is
is you know having the conversations
first
getting a group of people who are ready
to act
and whether you live in a legislative
state or a ballot initiative state
acting making sure that you get involved
and and start having these conversations
and creating a group around it
and and really fighting against the
the doubting of viability
you can point to maine who passed ranked
choice voting you can pack
point to new york city you can point to
um
alaska now in pass passing final five
and hopefully soon you'll be able to
point to a whole lot more states
in terms of being a viability
um credible
sources of viability for these uh
initiatives
what um you know what's been the
response there in alaska
you know i think um i'm guessing the
political parties thought
never thought that this would be passed
or how they responded to
um to the change you know it's been
it's been pretty quiet since the
election um
they haven't said anything either way i
think they're starting to plan for
the next few years the next election
and they've reached out to us and we've
actually seen
a growth in our support people who were
once against us
who are saying look you won this is the
will of the voters
let's start planning and making sure
this goes well we're working with the
administration
um the the current state administration
the governor's office to make sure that
these policies are implemented
to the intent and will of the voters and
and they welcome us with open arms which
is fantastic
and and really we're seeing
legislators and voters say we're excited
for the next election
because we're going to have a better
election system we're going to have
our election system that we put into
place and so
really what you've what we've seen is
that 51
that this was passed by grow to 60 62
and hopefully it'll keep on growing wow
so um do you have aspirations for office
or
are you content to kind of lead the
charge in
in this voting effort i really enjoy
just leading the charge in this voting
effort it is um
you know i'm a young guy who really
enjoy
has enjoyed working on candidate
campaigns for candidates of
all uh all political um
beliefs but really under one umbrella of
wanting to get what's
right done um and so
seeing this this policy change in this
electoral system change
through to the end and through to uh
making sure that it stays for years to
come
is really important to me and so in the
near future
no no political aspirations other than
making sure the will of the voters is
upheld here
what do you think um you know when you
look at our national scene
you know uh obviously there's gonna be
big change in alaska what is it to take
to
to tip the balance in in in in our
national scene so that we have
more uh balance you know is it are we
gonna have to get every state involved
or is it
just a few states will start to begin to
see a difference
i think it's i think it really is going
to be a slow roll for a little bit
i think it's really um important for
states uh like alaska
to take it upon themselves to change
their own voting system
to answer the question of what do we
want from our elected
um officials but more so what do we want
to incentivize with our
electoral system do we want to
incentivize party pandering and
political strategy and and paying
paychecks of
political operatives or do we want to
take it upon ourselves to make the only
incentive
um to to have a message
and have a policy and platform that
aligns with over 50
of the voters in any given state um so i
think really as i
look across the nation it's it's going
to be one state at a time
um trying to pass this for the
betterment of
their electoral system and then finally
hopefully we'll get a fast roll
and get some great electeds up in up in
washington dc who don't look at
at it as a lifelong career but rather
they want to go down go down to dc and
and get a job done
and and get the job done that that
serves their state
their constituents and and make sure
make sure at the end of the day that
um our democracy is intact and so
also when i look at national events i s
i see
people on on both sides of the aisle
and seeing them say essentially the same
thing
in the fact that we have a lot of
problems with our current
um current system and and whether you
talk to a
a republican or a democrat or an
independent
the one thing that everyone can agree on
is that they're not very happy with
what's going on
in in politics and they don't want to
talk about it
and and so when i see that
it's it says to me that well it's never
been a better time
to to attack this system and make sure
that
we fix it for ourselves um ourselves
being the voters
when when you look out there at kind of
some of the states that are looking at
this
are there any that have reached out to
you that come to mind do you think that
are close maybe in 2022
to to taking the step you know a lot of
states
um have reached out and and
it's from oregon to florida to arizona
to georgia
to all of these different places that
are saying
you know could this be our time to do
this
and you know there's a lot of time
between now and
2022 and a lot of
landscape changes political strategy
changes
um but i would say every state is on the
hot seat to try and get this done
we i think i personally as one person of
this team
have been reached out to by at least
25 states um if not more
and just people people getting my email
off the
off the website and saying i want to
talk to this guy and
i of course i'm like well this is great
i'd love to talk to you about what we
did in alaska
and i love to talk so uh
we i would say when i look across the
nation
um one that point kind of
uh one state or a few states that
um come to mind are you know maine
could could really do well with a a
final five
system in their primary they still have
closed primaries
massachusetts they had a ranked choice
voting ballot initiative on the ballot
last time around and it was a close
campaign
a very well run campaign and it came up
short
i think they're right to have another
ballot initiative possibly a final five
ballot and it should come up soon
georgia is a legislative state that one
looks like a really
prominent area in terms of the fact that
you know they had a campaign they have
runoffs for their statewide campaigns
and they had campaign and political
season that lasted
what to to what felt like to to
georgians
um you know two years because it was
it was uh quite a few elections and a
lot of money spent and so
i would say when i look at georgia um i
would say
you know probably most of those people
uh
might not necessarily like having their
mailboxes full to the brim with
political mailers or they're
having to answer their door five or ten
times a day
on being reminded to vote for this
person or the next
and so that might be a good area and so
really name a state and we can we can
say why it's a good idea to attack it
in 2022 with these policies
so um term limits do you think that
if you go this route it obviates the
need for term limits because
um you know the candidate or the
um the the senator or the representative
if they're not doing the job they're
going to get voted out anyway what's
your what's your opinion
so do we need to go the extra step of
turn limits or or
just having the ability to you know
vote in this way should obviate the need
for that
you know i think it's all predictions at
this point because we haven't had
an election under the current system but
what i will say
is is term limits um the best term limit
is is being having a system that
is the most representative of the people
acting in that system
um the voters and so really making sure
that the need for term term limits comes
from
this idea uh in my experience
that people have been down there too
long and they're making this a career
and they're not
in tune with the voters anymore and so
they need to need to
you know get out procedurally and be
term limited out
the problem with that is that you lose
some institutional knowledge
you may lose a a representative or a
senator
who actually was was the best for their
constituents and actually always working
on behalf of their constituents and if
the constituents want somebody in there
for
a hundred years then they should have
that choice
and so what i would say is is truly
give them that choice with the most
representative electoral system
that you can find and and we landed on
final five final four voting and
thought um yeah this would be the most
this would
this would take away some of the need
for
term limits because now we can
really truly make sure that if we have a
representative
in washington dc or in juno or a senator
in either place
that they are truly supported by
over 50 percent of the um of the voters
so you mentioned massachusetts in new
york uh how did their programs compare
to yours
did yours go farther is it you know how
how do they how do they uh match up
yeah so um new york city passed rank
choice voting for their municipal
elections
and so um they you know
does that include the mayor i believe so
but i i would have to check um
but and and so municipal
municipalities or cities across the
nation have adopted
um rank choice voting i think it's up to
cities now maybe more and they're using
ranked choice voting you know san
francisco
oakland um minneapolis st
paul a lot of cities are using ranked
choice voting a lot of parties are using
rank choice voting for their primaries
um and so that's how that one's
different
there's only one election massachusetts
now
had ranked choice voting only
and so ours uh
does not have rank choice voting in the
primary election
we have a top four open primary where we
are voting under traditional voting
methods um
and so the two so just whoever gets the
top four that gets the highest number of
votes
yes yes and those move on and then we
have
uh ranked choice voting in the general
and so
in maine um they had ranked choice
voting in both the primary and the
general
um and then massachusetts i believe was
ranked choice voting in both the primary
and the general the other thing that
ours had
was um that probably sparked the most
controversy
um and probably was the motivating
factor for folks
uh to come out against us was the dark
money provision
um we wanted to shine a true light on
the source of funds
um coming into our state and as our
state goes
up each year in record-setting spending
for non-presidential and presidential
years
it's become ever more apparent that we
need more
financial disclosure and you know
justice
kennedy who wrote the majority opinion
in citizens united said it best
and i'm paraphrasing here but he said
the decision in citizens united and the
amount of money
um will become arbitrary because the the
disinfectant
for corruption and all of this money
will be states accepting disclosure laws
um and strengthening their financial uh
disclosure laws and that'll be the
disinfectant
well it had been about a decade since
that decision and we hadn't
updated our financial disclosure laws
and so we decided that
we needed to and um you know that
we were we were biting off a big bite of
the apple and we were hoping we could
chew it and
ended up being able to chew it just buy
a hair
um and uh and ever since it's past like
i said it's
it's definitely grown in support what
um what what exactly are those
disclosure laws what uh what do people
have to disclose
yeah so let's say you have
three entities you have this
massive funder this really really really
wealthy person
this intermediary national pac super pac
called apple pie for america and they
want to support
me for congress in in alaska
so what they would do is they would come
in
and give it to an independent
expenditure group
which would go towards supporting me but
my campaign can never talk to the
independent expenditure
group it's a shadow campaign essentially
that either goes to support me or oppose
my opposition and
all of this money comes into the
independent expenditure group that has
essentially no
financial um
contribution limits from pacs and super
pacs and so that super pac gives a
million dollars to the ie
and that ie spends a million dollars in
the state of alaska which
can go a long way and the voters look at
the financial disclosure laws
or the financial disclosures from this
independent expenditure group and go
ah apple pie for america of course one
million dollars
well they don't know what you know
voters don't know what apple pie for
america is it could be
have been set up six months outside of
the election
um and they have no idea about the
platform they have no idea about its
donors until february
when the irs reports come out well
february information in february doesn't
do much good
in on november third of the year prior
and so what our disclosure laws said was
if you're gonna spend money apple pie
for america if you're gonna spend money
in alaska
we need to know where those dollars came
from if they're over two thousand
dollars
we need to know exactly who those um
dollars came from and the tr and it says
that the burden is on apple pie for
america to provide
the true source of the funds being
anyone who earned or
inherited those funds
so the um what do you think you're going
to find
when uh when that when that begins are
they just not going to donate or
are you expecting to find um people that
you thought were there what's your
what's your belief
um you know i think that uh i think what
we're going to find
is that i think political spending may
go down
a bit for the first few years as people
get used to the new laws
but hopefully what we're gonna find is
that people are comfortable with
putting their name next to something
they're doing in a state they've never
been to
um and you know my mother always told me
if you're gonna do something you better
be
okay with your name being next to it and
so
i think what we're gonna find is that um
you know journalists our level of public
information
through our media and our reports that
are
uh researchable and and
can inform voters is
they're all going to increase and
people's knowledge of
of where money is coming from and who
what the
politics behind this funding is we're
going to find out more about that
and something that i'm really excited
for is is that
when i read the local paper here the adn
the anchorage daily news or alaska
public media
or alaska's news source i'll read
something that
informs me off of who are the people
behind the candidates
and tells me a little bit about what
those people's platforms are because if
if there's something in their platform
that leads them to
uh supporting state house candidates
in alaska to the tune of half a million
dollars well it must be something pretty
important in their platform so i better
know about that
um and so i i'm i'm really excited and
think that
um our our level of journalism
will our ability to put these into
newspapers and
into the public knowledge um is going to
go up which is really exciting
so do you have a a hero so to speak in
in politics is it somebody that inspired
you to get involved like you
like you are i would yeah i would say
my my former boss um gary cannot
representative gary knope he did pass
away during the campaign
um in a in a pretty big tragedy
uh accident um but i would say he
really played a part in in a massive
part
and he's a republican the other one is
the former senate minority leader
senator berta gardner who i lived with
when i came up here from alabama and i
was
i was a republican at the time and went
to living with
a a woman who was the senate minority
leader as a democrat in the state of
alaska
and we sat around her dinner table for
hours
debating the issues and i am a youngest
sibling so
i like poking holes in both sides and so
i'd debate with gary just as much i
debate with berta those two people and
and also my
my english teacher in high school who is
uh
andrea simmons she definitely um
played a massive part in making sure
that i got into politics
well shea you may not consider yourself
this but i think you're a great patriot
and i really appreciate the work you're
doing for alaskans
and americans i think this is so
important that we get involved that we
that we actually reform our political
system it has become too partisan
um dc is where i live and uh i get a
face full of it every single day and i
absolutely abort so i'm so
excited to be able to meet you and talk
to you and and
really um introduce you to you know our
audience here at generally speaking so
thank you so much for taking the time to
talk to
talk to me keep doing what you're doing
inspire others
and work for the american people well
thank you so much it was really an honor
being on your show and
and i i think the same of you so i i
really appreciate this
and i hope you have a great rest of your
day
thank you thank you well if you stayed
to the end i hope you enjoyed the show
be sure to leave comments below like and
subscribe
thank you for coming on generally
speaking i'm general spalding